SPEAKER: Today at Google, we're
excited to welcome Mr. Noam
Cohen.
Mr. Cohen is a former technology
columnist at the New York Times
where, beginning in
2007, he wrote the Bit
By Bit column, which covered
the impact of the internet
on society.
He recently left the Times in
order to write his first book,
which he is here
today to discuss.
It's titled, "The Know-It-Alls:
The Rise of Silicon Valley
as a Political Powerhouse
and Social Wrecking Ball."
The book is an
incisive biography
of some of Silicon Valley's
most venerated leaders.
It offers a critique of the
current state of the internet
and explores the implications
of radical individualism
on democratic ideals
in American life.
Please join me in welcoming
to Google, Mr. Noam Cohen.
NOAM COHEN: Thank you.
Nice to be here, and I feel
it's a little like going
to the belly of
the beast, but it's
been very welcoming in here.
Nice and warm in the belly.
I'm glad to be here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER: So I'd to just
start at the beginning.
Where did the idea for
the book come from?
NOAM COHEN: Right, so,
you know as you mentioned,
I was a tech writer at the
Times for a lot of years.
I would write in
the business section
but I often would not
write about businesses,
I'd I write a lot
about Wikipedia,
I'd write about free software.
I was really intrigued by
how the internet and the web
was changing society and
little less about the business
implications of it.
And you know, I was
always kind of curious--
I was in the business section,
but I just didn't really--
I didn't really focus on it
companies and such like that.
But over time I kind
of couldn't keep
my head buried to see that how
these great innovations were
becoming part of businesses.
And I wanted to
sort of see how we
got to our current situation.
The situation where so
much of our interaction
with the internet is
through big companies
like Google and
Amazon and Facebook.
And I really felt there
was a corrosion coming,
so that sort of values
that were being caught
through these companies
and through the internet
or becoming quite
libertarian and quite
a threat to the
social fabric and what
I would call libertarian ideas.
And of course, the meddling
in the 2016 election
became this real watershed.
So I had these
concerns, but it kind of
made things much
more clear as to why
the stakes were very high.
That our democracy
could be at stake.
Rather than kind of being a
critic of Silicon Valley being
like, is Google making you dumb?
Or do young people care about
privacy, the question was like,
are these companies kind of
compatible with democracy?
So that give my book
a lot of urgency.
And obviously, I worked
on it before that,
and I was trying to kind of
look at these kind of questions.
And when I kind of came
up with-- an operating
idea of the book is that there
are these two forces that
account for what's going on.
One force is the history
of computer science.
Like you said, I went
really deep dive,
looking at how computer
science can be developed
and also Stanford.
And so until I'd
done the book, I
hadn't realized how important AI
was to the history of computer
science.
I guess maybe
that's well-known--
I didn't realize that is what--
I focused one chapter about
John McCarthy, who was
this fairly significant figure.
Particularly in
Google, I would think
he'd be very venerated,
like you were saying.
I know that early on, he was in
the same building with Sergey
Brin and Larry Page and they
were grad students at Stanford.
He came early on to Google
to visit the campus,
and I was really struck
that even the Google search
engine early on used McCarthy's
website, its early website
at Stanford-- they used
that as a way of proving
that personalized search
would be much better.
They took all the knowledge
you get from McCarthy's website
and they plug it
into their page rank
and it produced some
much better results.
So this McCarthy is such
a fascinating figure,
and he's sort of not been
written about that much.
He becomes like a surrogate
for computer science for me
that he was born to communist
parents, he was a math genius,
and over time, he was fascinated
with artificial intelligence
and wanted to create
a thinking being.
And so this early pioneer
of computer science--
he created a list program--
he was motivated by
making a thinking being.
And that's kind of what's
driven computer science history,
I found.
So I was looking at that,
so what does that mean,
McCarthy became a
mentor to the hackers?
And it means that
that idea of seeing
a machine as a person and
a person as a machine,
and this idea that computers
can really save the world,
was really important
to McCarthy.
And that thread is what I'm kind
of borrowing from Steven Levy.
So I call it the hacker
ethic, this idea that
being highly individualistic,
what you see on the Google
campus, people are free
to do what they want,
really challenging authority,
and also kind of not
very valuing
intelligence very highly,
and not kind of
caring about diversity
of women or minorities
and sort of this idea
that merit and intelligence is
what gets you where you are.
So that was one thread,
was, this history
of computer science.
I went deep into
that and McCarthy.
The second thread was Stanford.
I kind of learned
how Stanford became
so crucial to the idea of
entrepreneurship and the idea
that you should take
innovations that come,
research from your alumni, your
students, and your faculty,
and put them to the market.
And that kind of
began with this fellow
who has a chapter in a book,
Lewis Terman, who brought
Hewlett-Packard together.
These two graduate students
of his in the '30s.
He said, you two should
go to business together.
You gave them some
money to start up,
he gave them their first
contract with Walt Disney back
in the 30s-- and he sort
of preached this idea
that research should have a
practical business-related use.
And that, he thought, would help
Stanford rise up in stature.
When he took over as
provost in the 50s,
Stanford was considered
this kind of middling school
for kind of well-off
people in Los Angeles,
like a quote I saw.
And by the time he left,
Stanford was going way up.
And, of course, we now
today see how many companies
have come out of Stanford, and
that money finds its way back
to Stanford.
Stanford is this rich, booming,
highly-prestigious school.
So those two threads,
kind of the hacker ethic
and the entrepreneurism
is kind of where I see how
we got to where we are today.
I felt like I got an
answer to my question.
SPEAKER: So it sort of
seems like in the book
you trace a long period of
time starting with McCarthy.
Is that the '50s?
NOAM COHEN: Yeah, he
was this figure, right?
So he is known for being kind
of a mentor, Uncle John they
called him at MIT, the
mentor to the hackers.
In the '50s at MIT, he taught
first sort of computer science
class or freshmen in the '50s.
And I think what was really
vital about McCarthy too,
which I talk about
in the book, is
that this idea he came up
with, time sharing, which
was that, prior to time
sharing, the computers were
these mainframes that
you had to approach
like as priestly class.
You had to kind of
go to an operator
and give them questions,
and they would come back
like [INAUDIBLE] answers.
And instead, he said, no, we
should have terminals hooked up
to this one main frame,
so lots of individuals
can interact with the
computer directly.
I think for him that
was key to AI, this idea
that if you're going to
make a thinking machine,
they should interact with
as many people as possible
and sort and learn from
people and sort of judge
them on how they
interact with people.
So he became a real force for
making computers much more
accessible, which again, we're
living with today, this idea
that computers aren't an oracle,
they're a personal thing.
Really, the cloud I think
even comes from that idea.
SPEAKER: So John
McCarthy-- that was sort of
in the first
generation of hackers,
who had that the hacker ethic.
And then later this sort of
entrepreneur Frederick Terman
at Stanford sort of
brought this other side
of what you called
the know-it-all, sort
of the business-minded
application side.
How would you
distinguish, say, McCarthy
in the first generation
of hackers' motivations
and the way that they
approached computing
and what they wanted
computers to do for society--
how would you distinguish that
with what maybe entrepreneurs
in technology are doing today?
NOAM COHEN: I was
really struck that how
idealistic McCarthy was.
McCarthy never
went into business.
And this idea of a
singularity, right?
This idea that computers are
going to get smarter than us,
we people, and then
eventually, smarter
computers are going to
make even smarter computers
and then it's like
off to the races.
So he, in '68, gave
a lecture at Stanford
that raised that exact point.
But rather than fearing this
would mean that computers
are going to take over
the world that they'll
be our overlords, he
said, when that happens,
the first thing we do
is, we ask the question--
hey computer, we made you,
you're smarter than us,
what should we do now?
He believed intelligence
was a good thing.
He didn't fear it,
I assume he thought
having a thinking computer
would explain the cosmos.
We have telescopes; we're
trying to understand
what we're doing here--
a smarter computer is
going to really get
an answer-- what is this?
What is the universe?
And so that idealism and that
almost impractical nature
I think was true of that
era of AI researchers.
And you read about the
Stanford lab, right?
McCarthy made this transition.
He went from MIT--
he was sort of frustrated
by the weather, frustrated
by other things, and he
moved to Stanford in '62
and recreated the
MIT lab at Stanford.
And it became this real
hothouse of this really
kind of innovative and also
just like free spirits.
And you know, there was
actually Russell Brand--
the famous founder of
the Whole Earth Catalog--
who wrote this profile of the
Stanford AI Lab in the '60s.
It was when they were making
the first video game Space War.
It just was a very loosely
goosey and not nearly as
efficiency-driven kind of world.
Now, cut to today--
I think partly it's out
of the failure of AI,
is how I see things,
that AI didn't
succeed in creating this
cosmos-understanding thinking
being.
Rather, it created something
that kind of imitates
a person and that quality has
been very useful for businesses
because these algorithms
aren't actually
answering the big questions.
They aren't approaching
what we consider special
about human intelligence.
They're just sort of doing
things much more efficiently.
And that lack of
success has actually
led to these businesses making
great hay of that development.
I'll put it this way-- it
was interesting to watch,
you talk about looking
at the history of this--
the history of chess
computers itself
is a fascinating thing, right?
When McCarthy created
one of the first chess
programs-- it was really
his under-graduates
that did all the work, right?
He was the professor.
And it was amazing
to think that chess,
this intellectual activity
that only people who
smoke pipes and are
reading great books,
and that computer could
be better than a human,
it's amazing.
So it won its first
match, and in fact, there
was a famous critic of AI,
this guy Hubert Dreyfus,
who was at Berkeley, right?
A philosophy
professor that kind of
questioned the whole
idea of AI, and he said,
and what is AI doing anyway?
It can't any beat a
12-year-old in chess.
So they became
obsessed with beating
Hubert Dreyfus at chess,
which they did in 1966.
It was a big match because
he didn't back out of it,
and they beat Hubert
Dreyfus at chess.
The New Yorker wrote
about it as a big event.
And so you think that was
a huge accomplishment,
and of course now,
chess computers
are better than any human--
but of course McCarthy realized
that, what was succeeding at?
It wasn't thinking better.
It was just calculating
so much faster.
And so in that
sense, that speaks
to exactly what we're at.
We need a computer--
he would never
have dreamed that a computer
could have been better
than any chess match?
It was a really ambitious
thing to think about.
Now that's easily done,
but it doesn't have
any real payoff in that sense.
So I think today,
people are more focused
on making a great
chess computer,
and that's an awesome thing, and
McCarthy would have been like--
was, in fact--
that's not anything.
So that's the
difference, I'd say.
The idealism, the
ambition maybe.
SPEAKER: And you think it's
the market influence that
maybe shifted the focus?
NOAM COHEN: Well, I don't know.
I think maybe McCarthy would
have just not done anything
with it, because if it
didn't answer his question,
he would have moved on.
I think the markets
at least show
there is a real utility
to it, a real utility
to these algorithms
that have a real power.
It wasn't what he
was interested in.
I'll tell one other--
I'm almost thinking
about the next thing
I want to write about, and I
mentioned a bit in this op-ed I
wrote in the Times about Eliza.
To me, Eliza, this program,
is really interesting to me
about all of these questions.
Because Eliza was written
by this MIT professor Joseph
Weizenbaum who was a bit of
a rival McCarthy's, and it
was a chat bot, and really
crude, he wrote it so quickly.
And it just imitated
a therapist, right?
So it just sort of spit back
what you would say to it.
You'd say, oh, I'm really
nervous to be here.
Why are you nervous?
Well, you know, my family
doesn't like to talk a lot.
Does your family bother you?
I'm just asking very open-ended
questions with no knowledge,
using key word, right?
Key words that were kind
of repeated back to you--
so Weizenbaum made
this program and was
shocked to realize that his
own secretary was interacting
with it.
And he's looking over her
shoulder, and she's like,
can you give me
some privacy please?
And he's like, what?
You're just talking to
a bot I made in one day.
And he realized there was a
huge power to these computers
and a huge ability
of people trust
them and to be manipulated.
And he was interested in that.
So I think the same
thing, that McCarthy just
wouldn't have been
interested in using computers
to imitate people,
to manipulate them.
That wasn't what he was doing.
I don't think it's a
market force thing,
I think market people
saw that's a great tool.
SPEAKER: What is that,
you label something there,
a libertarian in the book?
What is that?
NOAM COHEN: Right.
I guess I should focus.
The point I'm trying to say
is that the know-it-alls
are kind of promoting a
libertarian ideology, very
hyper-individualistic ideology.
And I think it comes from
a variety of reasons,
like the hacker ethic is part of
that, the good part of saying,
leave me alone.
I fly my own free flag.
And so it's part of
that, but also it's
just the breaking
down of institutions
is also part of it.
And kind of people
doing more on their own.
So to me, the
libertarian is kind
of people who don't see
the costs of libertarianism
but they see the
good side, which
is the freedom people have.
I was telling them beforehand,
like Elon Musk is maybe
an example of this or Jeff
Bezos I think is another,
because he's a big supporter of
Libertarian Magazine, Reason.
And he identifies I
think in a lot of ways
with libertarianism, but
also I think sees himself
as a little bit liberal.
And it's this idea that, oh,
I take ideas from both sides
or, I see the
libertarianism allowing
you to have gay marriage,
and have freedom
that smoke wherever you want--
and then sort of not seeing
the world government.
Seeing government as a
bad thing-- so, saying,
government is actually hurting
people, it's limiting people.
There's no freedom
to do your own car,
or that free speech limits.
So rather than seeing
free speech limits
as about protecting
people who are weak--
minorities and women-- you
can see free speech protection
is clamping down an individual.
I can't say what I want.
So you can kind of frame
it like a liberal thing.
I think that's kind of
saying that libertarians,
they're trying to put a
much more positive spin
on libertarians.
Maybe not like this kind of
feudalism of libertarianism,
which is that we're all
in a battle for resources
and let the strongest win--
that's bad PR.
I think this is a more kind of
humane face for libertarianism.
I think that's kind of what is
coming out of Silicon Valley.
It's not this harsh,
you know, other
than maybe Peter
Thiel, or something.
It's not a harsh
libertarian view.
It's this more soft, we
want everyone to excel.
And that's what it's about.
It's that individualism.
So yeah, I think
that's a key issue.
SPEAKER: And so in the book, you
critique the sort of internet
that's evolved out of this
sort of libertarian ethic.
It's sort of commercialized
and centralized--
and you say, in
place of that, we
should be focusing more on
local, like local institutions
and newspapers, trade unions--
what was the inspiration
for that in your mind?
Who were your influences that
may have shaped your thinking?
NOAM COHEN: I guess I was
saying, an important thinker,
this philosopher--
[INAUDIBLE] Moller
Okin, who wrote a book
about, it's called,
"Justice, Family,
and--" it's a critique
of libertarianism
from a feminist perspective.
And it really spoke to me,
because basically, what she
was saying is that,
libertarianism
has to devalue women.
It's not a coincidence that
there aren't tech sisters.
Tech bros are a thing because
libertarianism is this idea
that you kind of arrive
at your station in life
on your own work and worth.
And it kind of
assumes that we all
land as fully-formed
adults and then
we kind of deal with how we're
going to allocate resources
in our society.
And she was pointing out
that, now, obviously, today we
have more equal share
over raising kids.
But fundamentally, young adults
arrived there through women.
And she was making
a kind of argument--
reductio ad absurdum
argument-- of saying
that if the extreme libertarians
say whatever you produce
is your own, she was saying,
well then, if women produce
children, do they own them?
She was trying to cut
through all of the fallacy
that we're just individuals
striving to get there,
that you're a
product of a family,
and then family is
part of a neighborhood,
that neighbor is
part of a society.
And so I think that that was
really influential on me.
To see that in some ways the
kind of male culture of Silicon
Valley and libertarian culture
of Silicon Valley were related.
It's kind of wishing away how
we got here and kind of just
wanting to be--
it's very adolescent,
I would say.
I say that in good and bad
ways-- adolescent instinct.
To be, I'm here, I want to
make my mark on the world.
You know, who cares?
Daddy, mommy, go away--
I'm in charge now.
But it's not true of society.
I think that's one
of the themes I
got to in the book was about
the fantasy of the internet,
that basically the internet
is imagining a world free
from a lot of the pull
of history and of racism,
misogyny.
I look at this famous document,
this John Perry Barlow
"Declaration of
Cyber-space Independence,"
which he wrote in the 1990's.
He's a founder of EFF, this
very important digital rights
movement.
He was a lyricist for
the Grateful Dead.
And he basically
just says, we're
making a world were there is
no racism, there is no gender.
It's a new world.
Go away, governments,
we're free here.
And it's like, that fantasy is
part of what the problem is,
and it's part of the
attraction obviously,
the internet-- who wouldn't
want to live in a world
where we don't have to
deal with a legacy problem?
SPEAKER: And so you say
that the internet should
resemble local communities, and
it should reflect that more.
Are there companies, are
there pockets of the internet
that you think are doing
that well or that you admire?
NOAM COHEN: Yeah,
I think it's funny.
I think that,
obviously, Wikipedia is
something I wrote a lot about.
And I feel Wikipedia--
part of what we talk about, the
problem with Silicon Valley.
I think, is also
the scalability idea
that everything has a scale.
And once you scale, once
Facebook has two billion users
and Google has more
than a billion,
you can't have a human touch.
So I think of Wikipedia--
it has bots, and it does
automate a lot of things,
but it fundamentally is still
aspiring to be human scale.
And people definitely
dissect about the problems
of Wikipedia.
And definitely, this appearance
of no hierarchy, but there
obviously are people
who are administrators,
and their clicks and
all that kind of stuff.
I mean to minimize that,
but fundamentally, those
are human problems.
So I look at something
like Wikipedia
and admire that it still aspires
to be a human-scale project.
I think that is a minimum
requirement for any kind
of internet project.
It has to have that human scale,
not the digital billion users
scale.
And we were kind of talking
about Tim Berners-Lee before,
and in this sense, this
is kind of what I think
Berners-Lee was talking about.
Early on, he wanted this editing
tool with a browser, right?
There was a big issue about
whether that first browser
he made versus the one that
Mosaic, the famous one Marc
Andreessen made that
became Netscape and became
the progenitor of all this--
would have an editing tool.
For Berners-Lee, why was an
editing tool so important?
It just was like a metaphor
or a way of making sure
that people could feel that
the internet wasn't passive,
the web wasn't passive,
that you were part of it.
And I think that
is just so vital.
I don't know how to describe it.
Obviously, you could say
that Twitter, and Facebook,
and Google are all about
giving people a voice.
So I totally get that.
But it's more the sense
of ownership of it
and creation that is
done in your sphere,
not in a company sphere.
So I just think that's what
I about with localness.
And I think that, it's
really interesting,
I was on a program, a
radio show in New York,
and a colleague that
used to be from the Times
was writing about
local newspapers
and was talking about how
local newspapers as we
know are kind of dying, and
that part of it is advertising,
even local advertising
through Facebook and Google
can be so targeted--
and it kind of, it's
like they found a way
to reach you want to
reach Bayside Queens,
they found a way to reach
Bayside Queens in a way that
doesn't involve being
in Bayside Queens,
or the way Bayside
Queens is organized.
It's just sort of
through other triggers,
and that's kind of a problem.
It's solving a lot of
problems-- getting local ads,
and reaching localities,
by it's not doing it
through a structure that's
useful, if that makes sense.
And that's kind of what
I'm getting at-- it's
not just the mere localness
or the mere individuality,
but part of a
structure, a society,
where we're all
aware of each other.
SPEAKER: Do you
think people become
less civic-minded when you
take that community out of it?
NOAM COHEN: Maybe
you've seen on Twitter,
people have been
putting this graphic
out a lot of the rise of
polarization of politics
and mapping that with the
rise of social networks.
Yeah, it's a sense--
I was talking with a
friend about this that when
advertisements are so
targeted, it can be targeted,
and not everyone sees them--
and I guess what people call
a filter bubble--
I don't act like I'm coming
up with new insights here.
These are kind of problems
that people saw all along.
I guess what I wanted
to do in this book,
rather than just
criticize, was sort
of explain in a
very understanding
way how we got here.
How did well intentions
end up in this wrong path?
And so to me, a
different interviewer
was asking me about
these mottoes--
don't be evil, whatever you want
to call it, whatever that was
at Google, or, move fast and
break things-- and it's like,
I don't think these are cynical
tricks that these companies are
playing.
I mean, they show
where it started from.
It's almost like it's
such a powerful tool,
these social networks are so
massive and so strong that
if we don't--
it's almost like you
need outside advice,
and we as a society
have to grapple with it.
Something I've talked
about a bunch was--
because, for some of
these appearances,
was just looking at the hearings
about the Russian influence
on the election.
I was struck.
There is a scene where Al
Franken, Senator Al Franken,
was asking the General
Council at Facebook
about whether he
could just pledge
not to take political ads
that were paid for in rubles.
Right?
It seems almost like a joke.
And the council said,
that's a very good signal,
we are really mindful of that.
Thank you for pointing it out.
He was like, can you just
say that you will not accept
political ads paid in rubles?
And he would not commit to it.
And Al Franken got
very frustrated,
and kind of yelled at him, even.
And I was thinking, why
would he not agree to that?
Such a straightforward pledge.
But I think fundamentally
it spoke to Facebook saying,
you, Al Franken, are
not telling us how we're
going to do our algorithm.
That's for us to figure out.
It's a good point you make.
It's an important signal.
We're going to factor it in and
we'll get back to you on it.
And I think that
arrogance is really
why the book's called
the Know-It-Alls.
It has to end.
We as a society have to
answer these questions.
It can't be that a handful of
leaders of these companies,
with all good
intentions, are going
to come up with the answer.
I've always had this motto of--
maybe it's a little
too self-deprecating--
but the wise man knows
he knows nothing.
I mean, the truly wise
person, the true know-it-all
would know that they need help.
And I hope that's kind
of where we're going.
SPEAKER: That's
the Socrates model.
NOAM COHEN: Yes.
Yes, exactly.
SPEAKER: So changing
gears a little bit.
So throughout the book, you
seem to have this resistance
to quantification.
So whether it be measuring
intelligence with IQ
or measuring the
impact of education
with different
number metrics, it
seems to you not only
to be reductionist
but also to be even
harmful in some cases.
And it seems in
today's world, it's
a common desire to
want to be data-driven
and to optimize around data.
It seems like you're
sort of a contrarian
and pushing back on that.
So could you talk a
little bit about that?
NOAM COHEN: Yeah.
And that's such
a great question.
This relates to journalism too.
You'll see these debates
about data-driven journalism
and I guess I'm always going
to think of a better story
as being more
effective than data.
And I guess I am suspicious
of this kind of reducing
such ineffable qualities like
intelligence to a number.
I do bring it back to that
history in the book of AI,
because I think fundamentally,
if you think a computer can
be a thinking being, it's
like, you're basically saying,
to be a thinking being
is just to have a head,
to have circuits in your brain.
And I think we
recognize that it's
a very odd image, to think
of just a brain being
all that is important.
I think about even
my own personal life,
it's like something my
wife and I talk about,
the mind-body
divide and the idea
that there is more to
life than just the mind.
And I bring it up because
it's seeing intelligence only
through what your brain
does, and not seeing
how you function in the
world is a real mistake.
And I think of it like,
it's ruthlessly efficient.
We were talking about how it
reminds me of, kind of, even
people who take over companies
and see their value if you
break it up and
sell this part off
and don't see the
whole of a company
or the whole of society.
You could argue that arguably
you look at what Facebook does,
it really basically
breaks our population up
into 14 categories.
And it's just pernicious
because it's not seeing a whole.
And I guess that is
data-driven; they're
breaking up 14 categories.
They're using data and analytics
to come up with those numbers.
I just think it's a mistake.
I guess it fundamentally
puts me, though,
not on the side of efficiency.
I think about,
obviously I had friends,
especially in the paper, New
York Times-- who really believe
in data-driven journalism.
I remember having a very good
friend, a very smart friend,
who explained to me that
the whole idea of being
hot in basketball, like being
on a tear, is just not true.
And I was like, it
can't not be true.
I've seen people.
And then he'll break down stats
and show you that it isn't.
And so I don't want
to sit there and cling
to things that are just
fundamentally not true.
But that said, I do think
there are these sort
of inexpressible qualities.
I don't know that efficiency
is the most important thing.
I think there are other
things that get lost.
I'll make one last
point on that,
and maybe bring it back to
sort of my haranguing tone,
but it's like--
if you focus on
efficiency, what am I
saying about we break up
companies or something--
you're extracting the most
value out of this thing
you have by breaking
it up, but you are not
looking at the costs.
It's very easy to
sort of dismiss
the costs of doing that.
And I think that if we just
put a number on intelligence,
you can find yourself lacking.
What if your goal
was to hire the best
people for your company
to solve a problem?
That won't necessarily
lead to the best results
because I don't
think you fully--
again, the wise man
knows he knows nothing.
You aren't going be able
to create a number of way
to judge intelligence the way
that is useful whatever project
you have in mind, I would say.
So that's why I'm skeptical.
I do know the power of this.
And I think part of
what writing this book
is sort of dealing with the
fact that these companies are
so successful.
I'd say the biggest push
back I get from people when
I talk about it is
this idea that people
love these companies.
So what are you talking about?
You're basically telling
people they don't know
what's in their own interests.
SPEAKER: So at the end of the
book, where do we go from here?
You say that to rely on
the companies themselves
to change the course
would be blasphemous
or something like that.
So why is that the case?
NOAM COHEN: It's
kind of what we're
talking about where it's
the humility that we need,
that we need us as a society to
come together and kind of come
up with some rules of how
we're going to live together
with these companies.
Things are moving so
fast that it's almost
like we need to slow down
and talk about it together.
I was struck that,
again, looking
at that hearing, that there
is a kind of consensus
on the Republicans
and Democrats.
The sharpest questioner
I thought at that hearing
was the Senator John
Kennedy from Louisiana,
that was asking a
lot of hard questions
and very suspicious about
all the data collection.
And so I think that yeah, I
do think we, going forward,
we need to empower people.
We need to maybe lessen
the power of the companies.
I talk a lot about regulation
and the European style
of regulation, European
buyers would maybe
say that the right
to be forgotten
is a violation of free speech
or however you want to view it,
but that it's a very
important value.
So I lean a lot on
regulation stuff,
and I can say that
people resist that.
And talking to a friend, I
think another way to think of it
is also, why not
empower people to get
more control of their data?
I saw the Times
today had a piece
about there should be
taxation on data collection
and I would more say, I was
looking back when I was reading
about McCarthy and
Weizenbaum, that in the 70s,
Nixon set up a
commission about privacy.
I guess people were really
concerned about medical records
and they're asking,
what should we
do with this new thing,
computerized collection
of data?
And they suggested that
corporations and the government
should have to report
what they have on you.
And it ended up that we only
said it about the government,
not for corporations.
This is before that.
Obviously, I'm not blaming
this on Google or Facebook
or any of those.
This was way before there
where big companies.
But I guess there was IBM, they
were people that had data--
so I think that might
be a step forward.
Rather than viewing
as the government--
I've been talking to people
about the power of narratives.
Maybe that's a better narrative.
Instead of the narrative
being government
should come down and
stop these companies
from doing what
they're doing great--
no, maybe we should
empower people
in the libertarian way
almost, sort of say,
you control your data.
And then give you more.
And might be a way of
sort of slowing the brakes
on a lot of stuff and
kind of getting people
to not participate in the
system that is causing damage.
So thinking of new
ideas, but I do
feel like that's a
very tough question.
What am I saying?
And I didn't want this
book to be only a screed.
I really wanted it
to be a look at how
we got here and a
look at, I guess,
in some ways these
unappreciated people and events.
Computer science and Stanford
and the pull of libertarian
ideas and why they make sense
to a certain group of people,
and why that is so
attractive but maybe
it would make sense
in a computer lab
but not make sense
in our whole country.
So same thing.
So I think that is
where I would go.
I would go breaking,
making things smaller
and giving people more
power over their data.
But it's so for us all to talk
about, I guess, is where I am.
I'm hoping it will
lead to a dialogue.
SPEAKER: I think that's
a great note to end on.
I think we can take
some audience questions.
Jessie.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: You talked
a lot about the data issue,
owning your own data.
That seems like it's
kind of at the forefront
of the public
conversation right now.
If you had to make
a prediction, do you
think any of this
stuff that's kind
of being proposed
legislatively to curb maybe
the monopolies that
Google and Facebook have,
will actually take into effect?
NOAM COHEN: Yeah, it I
had to make a prediction,
I would be kind of
leery about it actually.
I think that much
change will happen.
I think part of
what people believe
is this, at least there
are companies, right?
I was with some
person from a panel
that-- you know, imagine if
it was a Chinese company that
was the Facebook of America,
then how would we feel?
So I think in that
sense, especially
under this current
president with this very
populist nationalist view,
there's probably a real comfort
at least in having
these big companies be
American companies.
So I wonder what's
going to happen.
I think it's a
really fascinating
and I do think that the election
meddling has been a watershed.
It sort of shifted the public
consciousness, because prior
to something as
significant as that,
this idea that maybe our
democracy was tampered with--
and obviously, it was
tampered with in many ways.
But this was one outlet.
And maybe it was done kind
of without the people running
these companies noticing--
that kind of woke up
people and gives it
a much greater gravity.
These other kind of concerns
become much more trivial
about what these social
networks are doing.
Now I think it has
woken everyone up.
I genuinely don't know how
it's all going to shake out.
I think there are polls
in all different ways.
I mean, it's going to
be amazing to watch.
And I do think, who
even knows what's
going to happen in our country?
If there's a wave, election,
maybe Democrats sort of bounce
back, that could change things.
Especially a populist
Democrat might
have a very different
view in all of this
than a populist Republican.
It's a great question,
something like I'm
going to be watching
very carefully for sure.
SPEAKER: One more
question it that's OK.
I guess you could read
your book and then become
kind of just a hard-line
kind of Luddite.
What's the conclusion and
that's actionable after reading
your book in terms of
solving some of the problems
you outline that
might involve going
with the grain of history,
or kind of working with--
NOAM COHEN: I definitely do not
want to come off as a Luddite.
And I definitely believe
that these tools are amazing.
So I do think it
becomes sort of--
I guess why McCarthy was such
an interesting figure to me,
because that, and
this is something
that maybe David
and I were going
to talk about-- is this
idea that this research was
done under government auspices.
I mean, there was a really
interesting story of McCarthy.
I didn't get in the
book, and I can't even
believe this is even true--
McCarthy in the 70s had this
idea that, back in that day,
India had a hostile
relation with the US--
so there was all
this money that they
owed that US that they only
would give back in rupees,
right?
And he had this idea
that you should digitized
the Library of Congress
by having people in India
enter it in.
And he was thinking
of this in the 70s.
But he was thinking
about it not like,
I should do it so I can have
a company could own this,
but he was thinking that
like we, the government,
should do it.
I'm very much in favor
of research innovation
and I don't want to be
perceived as a Luddite,
but I think maybe
having more of this
being done under
government auspices,
and being thought of as
helping all of society and kind
of respecting people's
privacy and data
would be a great step forward.
So I definitely was very
worried that this book
would be perceived that way.
And I really struggled--
I guess that's why I also wanted
to talk so much about Wikipedia
because I see that such an
example of that, of technology
being used to really help
people understand the world
and without many
of the downsides
that I'm talking about.
SPEAKER: What about
like, for instance,
at Google we have it's
called 20% time, where you
can pursue your own projects.
So do you think there's an
opportunity there for people
to maybe pursue maybe
more local projects?
NOAM COHEN: I do.
I think you were saying that.
I think it'd be really
interesting to see
how you could create
projects that would force
these local community bonds.
I did write an
article for the Times
about Red Hook in
Brooklyn, which
is a very isolated
neighborhood in Brooklyn.
And it's a poor
neighborhood, it is
kind of becoming
gentrified-- and they
were trying to create a
mesh network out there.
And the way that they can use
that local internet to inform
people about their
community, and so I do
think-- and I don't
work to Google,
that would be amazing to
see what the minds here
would come up with.
Because what I was
saying was the community,
it's not just being able to
target a community through data
points, but like building
the connections of community.
I know that Mark Zuckerberg
talks about this a lot
with Facebook too.
But I mean, you'd have to do
this in a real genuine offline
way.
And I've seen that
being tried in Red Hook,
where they are trying to use
the tech, with young people
to get them to use
the Wi-Fi and maybe
when they access the
Wi-Fi they kind of
see things about
their neighborhood.
And events are sort
of, offline events
are sort of promoted
that way or something.
So it would be amazing to
see what could be done,
but I think those are the
kind of essential questions
about keeping it local,
creating stronger bonds.
So that would be amazing to see
what 20% time would lead to.
SPEAKER: All right.
Well, thank you.
NOAM COHEN: No
further questions.
That's great.
Thank you, David.
Thank you.